- Welcome to The Adorable Show,
the only show for
adorable enthusiasts.
My guest today is the embodiment
of all things adorable,
the star of Central
Intelligence,
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
Dwayne!
- Hey!
- [Both] Bloop, bloop, bloop!
- Boop boop!
(laughing)
- Have a seat buddy.
- Good to see you!
- It's really good to see you.
We've been wanting to have you
on the show for a long time.
- I have been
waiting for my turn
to come on The Adorable Show,
because I am, of all
things, adorable.
- You are kind of the
king of adorable and--
- You are the prince.
(laughing)
- I love laughing with you.
- Right.
(laughing)
- 'Cause we have that thing!
- We'll that doesn't
sound cute to me.
- I guess it's a good
time to bring out
our second guest
today, Kevin Hart.
- Cute dance, cute
dance, cute dance.
- Can I?
- Get it!
Get outta here!
(laughing)
- [Josh] Get in there!
- Cute scoot, cute
scoot, cute scoot.
- [Josh] (laughs) I
love the way you sit.
- It is cute though.
- (laughs) Stop it!
(giggles)
- It's not that funny.
- I'm sorry.
- Hey, is this cute?
- Don't.
- What's happening?
- (splutters)
- [Josh] Okay.
They're both adorable,
in their own odd ways.
- I mean, mine is
like, kids like mine.
- You know what
time it is, right?
It's time for the Adorable-Off!
- Yes, this is the one, where
I connect with the people.
- Dwayne, here's your camera.
I wanna see your
most adorable face.
- Excuse me for a second.
- [Josh] (chuckles)
That's amazing.
Do you have a name for that one?
- It's called the Ride.
- Thought it was
called Amateur Hour.
- Why?
- My turn?
- [Dwayne] I mean, that's not...
- [Josh] It's a good face.
Also it's sustainability,
look at how long he keeps it.
- Well, yeah, that means
there's a little problem.
- You, okay, maybe
you can stop it now.
It's time for the Lullaby-Off.
Each of you gets to comfort me,
you know, sing me to sleep or
whatever, however you want.
♪ Well, the thing
about night time ♪
♪ Is that you want ♪
♪ To get your eyes ♪
♪ As closed as possible, ah ♪
♪ So good night, sweetheart ♪
♪ May all your dreams-- ♪
- He didn't say you could do
that, he said it was just--
♪ Come true ♪
♪ Twinkle, twinkle, it's
not done, little star ♪
♪ How I wonder what you are ♪
- Alright, I think it's
over, I think it's--
- That thing in your back
is just a microphone.
Hey!
Hey there, there you are.
- Do you have a
go-to adorable voice?
- I don't!
What!
- What?
Gee gosh, would I
love a lollipop and
a stack of pancakes!
- [Dwayne] My adorable voice?
- Yeah, please.
- Okay.
Hey...
Hey.
- No.
- (clicks teeth)
- You won some of the
other challenges at least,
he was good at some
of the other things.
- Gee gosh, Mrs. McCarthy,
I would love to get
some butterscotch!
- That's a good tip,
any time you can put
a butterscotch in
there, that's--
- I know, I know, but
mine was a unicorn call.
- Well, I think it's clear.
It's a tie in the Adorable-Off.
- [Kevin] What? Oh.
- Well, I'll settle with
a tie then, because I--
- Let me ask my
friend Little Magoo!
Is it a tie?
No, I make no tie
because (mumbles) no tie.
Oh, gee gosh, Mr. Magoo!
The last thing I wanna
do is get a doggy lick!
- Our adorable king, Kevin Hart!
You got a puppy, look at that!
- Oh, I just gotta
scratch his fanny muggins!
- Okay, okay, had
enough of this.
- Thanks for coming, Dwane!
- Yeah, great.
- You are the best!
- Hey Dwane, I'm sorry.
- Go fuck yourself.
- Mr. Magoo, look at this!
We got a little
peauty pie padeant
pibby poopie puppy on our hands.
- Hey, since it's
The Adorable Show,
I just decided to come
with all things adorable.
These are my friends.
This is my family.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
we have our adorable king,
Dwayne Johnson--
- Thank you, ladies
and gentlemen.
- [Josh] And a far runner-up
way in the back, Kevin Hart.
- It's a pleasure
on the Adorable Show
and it's a pleasure
to be the king.
- Kevin, don't be
sad, we got puppies!
Everybody had fun!
We've got puppies!
(cheering)
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I love you more
than anything ♪
(laughing)
- That's great, that's good.
- Hewwo!
- I can hear you guys talking--
- [Josh] Hewwo, I am a cute
puppy talking (mumbles)
(calm carousel music)